have you ever seen wet cheetos before
today's the day
hi i'm joanna and today i'm going to
share with you a very special recipe
gummy bears you know them they're tiny
squishy bears
that you eat you know what i'm talking
about well you can make your own gummy
bears
at home you just need the molds and when
you make your own gummy bears
you can make them whatever flavor you
want
you're basically playing god so think
about that for a minute if you could
make a gummy bear that tasted like
anything what flavor would you choose i
didn't think about it very long and i
chose
flamin hot cheetos will it work i don't
know will it taste good probably not but
we're going to do it anyway
to make normal little tiny gummy bears
this is the kind of mold you can get
some sick freak decided that there
should also be
giant gummy bears for some reason and
you can get molds for those too
these are the big boys why would you
want to eat a gummy bear this size i
don't know
these bears don't have a mouth and i
guess that's so
they can't scream i don't know the big
special ingredient that you need to make
gummy bears
is gelatin gelatin is like a super power
you can use it for good or evil let's do
this
so these gummy bears only have four
ingredients we have
the flamin hot cheetos there's water
sugar and of course we have the gelatin
my plan is to put these flamin hot
cheetos with water
into the blender and make a sort of
flamin hot cheeto
juice i'm honestly not sure
how many cheetos is gonna be good for
this so we're gonna
wing it there's no established recipe
for flamin hot cheeto gummy bears
i am a pioneer water and cheetos
together at last
okay
how many opportunities are you really
gonna have to try cheeto juice
oh there's chunks it's gonna taste
amazing
oh boy salty actually it's not that bad
there's something weirdly good about it
so i think these gummy bears are
actually gonna be amazing
honestly this would make a good bloody
mary now that we have our delicious
cheeto juice it's time to make some
bears i'm measuring
out a cup of cheeto oh
look at the chunks amazing it's chunky
i'm gonna add a tablespoon of sugar
should i lick a spoon it kind of tastes
like spicy cereal
which they should make you take half of
your sweetened cheeto juice
and put it into a small saucepan i heat
this up on the stove until it's
simmering now i'm going to take about
one and a half tablespoons of gelatin
which is a lot and add it to
my remaining liquid now we take our hot
simmering cheeto juice and pour it
into the gelatin and sugar cheeto juice
turn it up baby
now i'm going to pour my hot cheeto
gelatin mixture
into a mold and then you take this fella
and you put them in the fridge
good night so now my little bear
children
are chilling in the fridge to solidify
for about
four hours i think i'm going to
experiment i want to make
a clear gummy bear with
flamin hot cheetos suspended in it
like one of those jello molds from the
50s and 60s that had chunks of food
floating in it
goodbye
let's go boys look at this
it's definitely going to be interesting
trying to get this
out of the mold and have it not fall
apart or look like a monster
i am nervous i put so much love into
these flamin hot cheeto bears
and i might destroy them in the end
oh boy oh boy
oh he coming oh hello
hey baby
[Music]
these are the ones that have the cheetos
suspended in them
let's see how these come out
oh boy wow
[Music]
[Music]
behold my robust sons
little ones are done too
[Music]
yeah that looks pretty good i would say
this is a giant gummy bear
and i feel a little bad because this
abomination
didn't ask to be created it didn't ask
to be born
but uh you know what i am stalling
because
i have to try these now and
i oh god okay
i mean they are fun to jiggle around i
feel like i'm gonna break it
unfortunately i will say this doesn't
necessarily
smell like food here's the original
here's the one with the cheetos
suspended inside
now kiss i have to try these i was less
scared to drink the cheeto juice than i
am to bite into this thing
do you think i should go feet or head
oh my god this does taste like a flamin
hot cheeto
the texture is what's frightening
this is the gummy bear with the hot
cheetos
suspended in it the fact that i have to
bite into one of these again
is hard
to accept okay i just have to bite this
okay i don't hate it i like this one
better
look at him i honestly thought these
would taste better let me see if i can
get
somebody else brave enough to try
it tastes like an old machine i would
say my takeaways from this experience
just because you can do something
doesn't necessarily mean you should i'm
sorry that i
did this to you
oops we don't have mouths
you